although most movies run for a couple of
hours some are just so epic that they
deserve a run time twice as long or more
so block out a few weeks on your
calendar get cozy and enjoy these are
the best films ever made that are over
four hours long
the 1963 historical epic cleopatra
begins shortly after the roman emperor
julius caesar wins a massive civil war
arriving in egypt he meets and falls in
love with cleopatra daughter of the
pharaoh with devastating consequences
for caesar
egypt and the entire roman empire over
the course of the movie cleopatra's
crowned queen of egypt has a child with
caesar and is eventually forced to pick
sides when rome is divided after the
assassination of her lover
initially angered that her son caesarean
was not chosen to succeed him cleopatra
is given another chance to interfere
with roman affairs when mark antony
approaches her and asks for supplies in
his war against the would-be emperor
octavian plenty of backstabbings and
bloody battles ensue and while let's
just say things don't turn out well for
anthony or cleopatra
it's not that often that you can say a
four hour film might be too short but
that may well be the case with cleopatra
the only real problem with this film is
that virtually every chapter of the real
cleopatra's life
could fill out an entire miniseries and
director joseph l menkowitz tried to
stuff
most of it into his movie so you gotta
give him credit for trying and creating
a straight up masterpiece in the process
if you were skeptical that the
long-awaited so-called snyder cut of
2017's justice league would live up to
the insane levels of hype it generated
you weren't alone snyder's filmography
is generally hit or miss and although
there has been the occasional bright
spot the dc extended universe has mostly
been something of a disappointment
especially in comparison to the far more
successful marvel cinematic universe
as such all the signs were pointing to a
snyder cut that was only superficially
different from but not better than the
so-so theatrical release
and boy were those signs wrong zack
snyder's justice league isn't exactly
dark knight brilliant by any means but
it's a truly worthy superhero team-up
outing nonetheless and a significant
improvement
over the original version i don't care
how many demons he's fought and how many
hells
he's never fought us not us united
it's also a triumph for snyder and his
fans who fought tooth and nail to get
this version of the film released after
years of being the butt of superhero
movie jokes and
putting up with destructive creative
meddling from the studio
in the end the release of this four hour
epic turned out to be one of hollywood's
greatest redemption stories
each of the three parts of the 2010
french german film carlos is longer than
the one before it and they're
all the length of an entire movie the
story follows the exploits of ilitch
ramirez sanchez otherwise known as
carlos the jackal
a real-life political terrorist who
committed multiple violent acts in
europe on behalf of the popular front
for the liberation of palestine
part 1 follows sanchez as he fights
alongside militants in the middle east
before moving to london
and then paris taking part in multiple
killings and bombings along the way
the chapter ends with him adopting the
name carlos and escaping capture by the
french police
part two focuses on a single real-life
terrorist attack staged by carlos in
which he kidnapped multiple opec
officials but then released some after
being unable to find any countries in
which he could seek asylum
this part ends with him becoming an
agent for hire for a number of nation
states and setting out to work within
the soviet sphere of influence
part three the longest of all follows
carlos's continuing operations in
eastern europe exploiting the
geopolitical instability in the region
to traffic arms between various clients
and
sponsor states perhaps inevitably the
movie ends with his 1994 arrest by
french intelligence agents
sound like a lot well it is which is why
carlos which was originally a tv
miniseries
clocks in at a truly impressive five and
a half hours
gettysburg the made for tv epic about
the civil war battle of the same name
shouldn't work half as well as it does
the decision to cast re-enactors with
their own uniforms and gear may sound
like a no-brainer
until you realize that the reenactors
don't tend to look much like scrawny
teenagers who actually fought in the
battles the movie depicts
on top of that the action is bloodless
the cinematography felt unimaginative
and dated
even in 1993 and you can very nearly see
the strings
holding up those goofy fake beards and
then of course there's the fact that the
director's cut goes on for
four and a half hours and yet somehow
the movie manages to be more than worth
a watch
randy alderman's score is one of the
most underrated of the 90s
and the main cast give career defining
performances
jeff daniels gives one of his best as
colonel chamberlain whose regiment is
forced to defend little round top
against seemingly impossible odds
tom behringer does a winning turn as
longstreet while richard jordan gives a
haunting performance as the confederate
officer low armistead
in the end against all odds gettysburg
actually shines
the epic 1984 crime movie once upon a
time in america is the final entry in
italian director sergio leone's once
upon a time trilogy
set in 1918 it follows two petty
criminals who lead a group of youngsters
from the slums of manhattan's jewish
ghetto to prominence in the world of
organized crime
naturally this movie has all the
mainstays of classic gangster cinema
extreme violence thick new york accents
drug use unscrupulous characters and joe
pesci
unfortunately studio meddling undermined
once upon a time's chances at the united
states box office
the lad company which produced and
distributed the movie was spooked by the
initial
six-hour two-part release that leone had
premiered in europe and trimmed it down
to 139 minutes without his consent or
involvement
inevitably critics and audiences alike
dislike this shortened release and the
movie pretty much
bombed at the box office nowadays at
least the full version of once upon a
time in america enjoys a much more
favorable reputation with critics and
audiences
leading to this film becoming yet
another cautionary tale of the pearls of
unwelcome studio interference kenneth
branagh's adaptions of the works of
william shakespeare are some of the most
popular and critically acclaimed to date
and one of the best of all is 1996's
hamlet a word for word recreation of the
original play this movie's cast is by
far its finest asset
alas
[Music]
poor yorick
i knew him horatio brana's turn as
prince hamlet
is obviously the heart of the movie but
derek jacoby's performance as king
claudius killer of hamlet's father and
the story's primary antagonist
is just as memorable in fact pretty much
every actor in hamlet has a good go at
stealing the show
although perhaps the most surprising is
the young pre-titanic
kate winslet who plays ophelia rana has
made a handful of tweaks and alterations
to the original play of course
most notably the 19th century setting
and the inclusion of a number of
flashbacks
but hamlet still manages to pull these
off without losing any of the magic of
shakespeare's original play
overall this movie more than justifies
its four-hour run time
the long-running artistic collaboration
between hungarian director belitar
and novelist laszlo krasnojorke came to
a head in 1994
with shatan tango this seven hour 12
chapter behemoth of a film
follows the exploits of the slick
tongued iremias who arrives at a small
farming commune
in the final days of communism and after
promising them good fortunes in a
wondrous new land
ends up making off with all their money
it would be nigh on impossible to even
go into the many many characters and
plot developments that feature
throughout chatan tango
all you need to know is that it's widely
considered one of the best films ever
made
boasts a rare 100 on rotten tomatoes and
is widely regarded as a masterpiece of
eastern european cinema
the 2003 italian historical drama the
best of youth follows nicola and matteo
karate
two brothers from rome who are forced to
navigate the difficulties of life in
post-world war ii italy
after a flood in florence nicola marries
julia a pianist and political extremist
before entering into
the field of psychiatry meanwhile mateo
joins up with the police and tries to
write society's wrongs with brute force
before meeting and falling in love with
mirella
a starry eyed photographer over the
course of the film's six and a half hour
run time these four characters
survive floods violence and extreme
political turbulence as they discover
all kinds of truths about themselves and
each other like many other super long
films director marco tolio jordana
originally wanted the best of youth to
be a tv miniseries
instead it was given a theatrical
premiere at the 2003 cannes film
festival
where critics overlooked its punishing
run time to give it widespread acclaim
as well as the coveted pre onset
if there's such a thing as a holocaust
movie for the faint of heart it's
probably not worth watching
still few of them are quite so
gut-wrenching haunting terrifying
enraging and unforgettable as showa
french director claude lanzmann's
nine-hour documentary
in his movie lensman examines every last
detail of the holocaust in eastern
europe beginning in the warsaw ghetto
a tiny district where that city's jewish
population was corralled by nazi
occupiers
before being shipped off to
concentration camps showa's story also
delves into the horrors of the labor and
extermination camps themselves the
millions of jews
communists roma and other so-called
undesirables who were imprisoned and
killed in them the administrators and
soldiers who ran them and the civilians
who lived nearby
perhaps most shockingly of all however
is showa's exploration of the banality
of the evil that characterized the nazis
crimes
although the movie doesn't really touch
on holocaust denial many of the people
interviewed for the documentary still
refuse to take responsibility for their
roles in the holocaust
it's moments like these that help make
lansman's movie not just an
incredibly uncomfortable watch to say
the least but a truly essential one too
as if its 11 oscar wins weren't proof
enough 2003's lord of the rings the
return of the king is one of the most
critically acclaimed and popular movies
of all time
it's one of those films where each
rewatch makes you fall in love a little
harder
in which every last scene is shot
performed and scored to perfection
you bow to no one as for the film's
finest moments
where do you even start there's the
tragedy of the fall of azgilliath
in which faramir leads his remaining men
on a chaotic retreat back to ministeria
there's pippin song performed for a
feasting denothor as faramir rides back
to us gilead on a suicide mission
there's the lightning of the beacons
gandalf's recollection of the afterlife
iowans battle against the witch king
frodo and sam's climb up mount doom
the battle at the black gate and perhaps
most famously of all the ride of the
rohirum which might be the most
fist-pumping beautiful edge of your seat
battle sequence ever put to film
the theatrical version of the return of
the king only actually runs for about
three and a half hours but the extended
edition
adds on a whole heap more including the
death of saruman
gandolf's confrontation with the witch
king and the hero's confrontation with
the mouth of sauron
now some say this version of the film is
overstopped heck some people think
the theatrical releases but the truth is
that the extended version of the return
of the king represents the very best of
peter jackson's momentous beautiful and
epic lord of the rings trilogy
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]